good evening welcome I'm happy to see
you here and I'm I'm especially
delighted uh about this special U uh
session of the MIT Communications Forum
I'm David thorburn professor of
literature and director of The Forum
beginning in January for the 20th year
and it uh is a kind of pleasure for me
uh to introduce our our moderator this
evening uh Seth manukan who is the
associate director of The Forum and my
expectations is will be my successor uh
I think he's been doing wonderful work
and I'm very excited about his presence
as associate director of The Forum
perhaps I can introduce the entire event
by uh mentioning that something like 15
years ago I gave a talk to a a a rather
Elite group uh in in Aspen Colorado
called the broadcasters convention and
they were Elite very wealthy
broadcasters people from all the major
networks uh and uh I was the only uh
professor of human of in any humanistic
discipline at this event so I uh
introduced myself by saying how pleased
I was to be there and uh how especially
happy I was that they were inviting a
humanist and I heard strange grumbling
in the audience didn't understand and I
went gave my speech but they but it
didn't I thought I was very good but
they didn't seem to respond very
effectively later a friend of mine who
had been in the audience told me I'd
lost them at the beginning because they
thought humanist meant human
being I hope our audience doesn't make
that error Seth thank you um thank you
very much David uh and thank you all for
coming out um I'm just going to stand up
for the introduction so no one mistakes
me as being part of this incredibly
illustrious panel um the format for the
evening we're going to talk among
ourselves for roughly the first hour uh
and then take questions from all of you
for the second an hour um a reminder
which I will remind you of again when we
begin the questions um please just
identify yourself when you ask questions
uh this is being recorded and an audio
uh recording and a video recording will
eventually be online um so without
further Ado uh I'd like to introduce the
four panelists here tonight um James
Carol who is to my immediate left uh is
an historian novelist and journalist um
his many works of fiction and
non-fiction include an American requium
which won the national book award um and
Constantine sword now an acclaimed
documentary uh he writes frequently
about Catholicism in the modern world uh
and in fact has a book coming out in a
couple of weeks is that right uh called
Christ actually the Son of God for the
secular age um putting us all to shame
he also just published a novel uh
several months ago called warberg in
July
um and uh he in addition to all that
he's a prizewinning columnist for the
Boston Globe and a distinguished scholar
and residents at suffk University um in
Boston uh Rebecca newberger Goldstein
who is to gyms left is a philosopher and
novelist um and the author of 10 books
including most recently 36 Arguments for
the existence of God a work of fiction
and Plato at the Google Plex why
philosophy won't go away
uh she was named the world economics
forum she was named to the world
economics Forum Global Council of values
and was also named the humanist of the
Year by the American humanist
Association in 2011 so um what better
person to uh to help represent the
humanities um she's the recipient of
numerous awards for her scholarship in
fiction including MacArthur
Fellowship Alan Lightman um uh who was
part of the reason why we're all here
today which I'll explain in a moment is
a physicist novelist and essayist um in
astrophysics he's made fundamental
contributions to gravitation Theory the
behavior of black holes um and radiation
processes and extreme environment
environments uh his 1993 novel
Einstein's dream was an international
bestseller uh and in 2000 his book the
diagnosis was a finalist for the
national book W and fiction he is
currently a professor of the practice at
human in Humanities at MIT um and
teaches with me in the graduate program
in science
writing uh Robert Weinberg um at the end
of the table is one of the world's
leading molecular biologists um and the
person who discovered the first Gene
known to cause cancer um his work
focuses on the molecular and genetic
mechanisms that lead to the formation of
human tumors uh and his recent work has
examined how human cancer cells
metastasize in 1997 President Bill
Clinton awarded him the national medal
of science which is the nation's highest
scientific ific honor uh he also is here
at MIT he's a professor of biology and a
founding member of the Whitehead
Institute for biomedical
research um so the Genesis for this
conversation here was actually a
Communications Forum that was held uh
last spring that Allan participated in
um it was called science and fiction uh
um along with a novelist named Ha
yagihara
and during the question and answer
period
um Allan and uh uh the head of the
literature program here Mary Fuller um
began talking about some of the
differences in sciences and the
humanities uh and Mary and Alan and I
all thought that this would be a great
topic to explore further um so we're
going to start just with some brief
opening statements from all four
panelists and then we will be off and
running so Jim you can
start good evening folks it's a great
pleasure for me to be here not
at least because I take the honor of
being invited to address a weighty
question but I'm also quite grateful to
be on the panel with these three folks
four including Seth but three to my left
whom I esteem and regard uh having en
encountered them powerfully in important
ways for myself over the years as
friends so it's a special privilege I
expect to learn a lot I remind myself
now of Admiral Stockdale you may
remember Admiral Stockdale who ran for
vice president with Ross perau and at
the vice president's debate he began by
saying who am I and what am I doing here
uh he also said when he was asked a
question I think it was about Medicare
uh I'm out of ammunition on that one ad
his greatest uh distinction at that
point was he was a hero of uh captivity
during the Vietnam war a man who really
was a hero in his Youth and alas in his
later years uh got caught looking
ridiculous I hope that's not what
happens to me here tonight I wondered
what I how I could identify myself to in
effect have a credential to be in this
conversation and what occurred to me to
say simply is that I'm a Christian
humanist
and I'd like to just put on the table
for our
conversation uh two figures who've been
extremely important in my own
intellectual life one is Peter abelard
whom you may remember as an
early 12th century philosopher
Theologian it's a distinction that
wouldn't have meant much to him he was a
scholar in Paris and was engaged in an
Enterprise that evolved eventually into
the University of Paris he's most well
known because of his affair with
Eloise uh which got him castrated
banished silenced and uh basically
removed from a position of real
influence uh in the life of Christendom
the point about abelard for me is that
he was an anti- Crusader at the point
when the Crusades were defining not just
the politics of Europe nent new newly
born Europe defining the politics of
Europe but also the ideology of Europe
and abelard was a dissenter from the
ideology that took hold of the European
mind in important ways but the most
important thing about him in a way was
what he was part of initiating so he was
a Latin scholar who was benefiting from
the arrival in Europe of the Greek
Classics translated by the Iberian
Peninsula translators Muslim and Jewish
and Christian but mainly Muslim and
Jewish Jewish and you know this story
well uh Rebecca is an expert on it the
the way in which the arrival of
Aristotle in the mind of Latin Europe
enabled a kind of recovery not from
Plato but from neoplatonism which had
been a deadly uh stult a stultifying
ideology in the mind of Europe and the
Christian world as it evolved into
Christendom and the arrival of those
great texts especially Aristotle
transformed formed the mind of Europe as
it was coming to be and initiated what I
recognize at least as a tradition of
Christian humanism a real Embrace of
basic human
value and the second and great figure uh
in track with abelard was Thomas aquinus
a century later so the 13th century by
then Tex of Aristotle much more broadly
available really defining arist uh
Thomas aquinus thought our subject is
knowledge and how human the humanities
knowledge in the humanities might differ
does it differ from knowledge and the
sciences and uh for me aquinus is the
perfect Touchstone for the beginning of
our conversation because again for him
that distinction the humanities and the
Sciences wouldn't have meant much to him
it was all knowledge and the thing that
really struck me when I began to think
about this was the Suma
theologica uh aquinus is great work
which in this was an ERA when you could
still attempt to summarize all that is
known so in that work he's summarizing
all that is known about theology but
what was striking to me was the subtitle
of that work was the nature and limits
of human
knowledge so it's a work Suma theologica
that is summarizing all that we know
about God but the subtitle is the nature
and limits of human knowledge so to talk
about God is to talk about human
knowledge that's what's interesting to
me and I want to just make five quick
points
about knowledge for our discussion I
probably will be the only person to make
this uh offer this frame of reference
because it's effectively the frame of
reference of a of a believer of Someone
For Whom the discussion of knowledge is
incomplete if it somehow doesn't grapple
with the question of God although
Rebecca knows more about the proofs of
God than anybody else I know although
with aquinus he only had five proofs of
God yeah the point number
one I know what a what aquinus
calls sensory knowledge Point number two
I know that I
know which is human knowledge dogs know
but humans know that they know which is
the beginning of
self-consciousness conscious ious n can
explain
everything which is the principle of
science as I understand it except itself
which is the principle of the limits of
science as I understand
them I know that I know includes I know
that I do not
know so the limit of knowledge is
essential to knowledge and in aquinus
that leads to his thinking about the vi
ativa the way to know is to begin with
what is not known and the only things we
can know for certain about God is that
we do not know God so not knowing is a
form of knowing and finally for him the
crucial thing is that the experience I
know moving to I know that I know me
moving to I know that I know and what I
do not know leads to the experience of
being
known I know I know that I know I know
know that I am
known there's a prerational
primordial Assumption of being
known and knowledge points to that
knower so all knowing has an analogical
character that moves inevitably toward
as I see
it the one who
knows the purpose of knowing and this is
my final
Point as aquinus
said is not knowing but love where does
knowing aim to go it aims to go to love
love takes off takes up he said where
knowledge leaves
off all right thank you um and uh if if
core's here if someone's here and wants
to close that door um out to the hall
that'd be great uh okay Rebecca well
actually alen and I decided to switch
you're going to switch okay so
Alan I mentioned Rebecca that I might
ruffle her feathers so she said I should
go first
um um so I can respond I'm happy to see
all of you here uh the topic tonight is
very dear to my heart um I'll be brief
and get directly to uh the point um I
think that both the science and the
humanities are
seeking understanding and
truth but those truths are different in
my
view in science the truth is the
external inanimate disembodied world of
atoms and stars and neurons and the
humanity Humanities the truth ultimately
lies in human beings our Natures our
society our values our motivations our
action
these are profound differences and I
think they need lead to many other
differences um one difference is in the
nature of
proof uh the mind of a human being the
human mind is is far more complex than
any physical system that we know of any
other physical system um even
neuroscientists who study the brain hav
yet begun to approach um the complexity
at the level needed to understand
thought Consciousness
self-awareness aesthetic judgment
motivation and Professor Weinberg can
correct me later here because human
beings are ambiguous and full of
contradictions the humanities cannot
prove things about history or literature
or philosophy in the same way that a
physicist can prove that a drop ball
Falls a distance proportional to the
square of the time of the falling or the
way that a biologist can prove that the
way that a nerve cell communicates with
another nerve cell is by releasing
dopamine or
acetycholine there's a sense of
rightness and wrongness with the
scientific
theory you can prove that Einstein's
theory is superior to Newton's Theory
it's far more accurate in accounting for
all gravitational
phenomena you can't prove that Jeremy
bentham's theory of of utilitarianism is
more or less correct than John Lock's
social contract theory that doesn't mean
that benm and lock are not brilliant and
stimulating thinkers of course they
are a closely related idea is the
repeatability of phenomena and science
versus the singular nature of events in
the
humanities the humanities of often deal
with people and events living in a
particular era or a particular social
milu and it's impossible to exactly
repeat the conditions to test an
hypothesis in science with the exception
of cosmology experiments can be repeated
thousands of times because the
conditions of the experiment can be
recreated in the
laboratory hypothesis testing is far
more definitive in science because of
this aspect of
repeatability in fact many humanists
would not describe their work as
hypothesis testing at
all ambiguity is more important in the
humanities in fact scientists hate
ambiguity scientists want clear crisp
answers to their
questions a swinging pendulum um is not
ambiguous you can measure the length of
its swing the length of time for a swing
precisely as a function of the length of
the string you can write down an
equation that accurately predicts the
position of the pendulum at a future
time by contrast you can't predict the
actions of a human being in a particular
situation unless it's a very simple
situation and you and you cannot predict
the actions of a nation of human
beings that ambiguity in human actions
which is uh always a good sign of a good
character in
literature is a result of the essential
complexity and unpredictability of the
human mind and the inability to isolate
all of the forces that affect human
behavior that doesn't mean that there
aren't many interesting important
question questions in Humanities
certainly there are it's just that these
questions often do not have unique and
definitive
answers as questions do in the
sciences and I wanted to end just by
saying and I hope Rebecca's been a
little stirred up here um I just wanted
to end by saying that that personally I
am very happy to be living in a world
that has both certainty and
ambiguity
when I'm flying in an airplane sitting
in a 500 ton machine that's thousands of
feet up in the air I'm very happy for
the certainty of physics and
aerodynamics but when I'm meeting a new
friend or making or debating a moral
issue or analyzing the social forces on
my favorite
novelist I find that the ambiguity and
the subtlety and the multiple points of
view engage me far more than would a
single and sterile
answer all right thank you Alan so I
guess the question is Rebecca did he uh
did he stir you up there
enough um well I'm it's a great pleasure
to be here and this is again for me um
an issue that uh that really resonates
with me um I started out College um uh
in physics and I in fact got all the way
through um and applied to graduate
school in physics but I was taking a
class in quantum mechanics and I kept
asking um my professor um how do we
interpret this and he was of that school
um the answer I mean what I was asking
was what is reality like according to
according to this Theory and he his
answer to me was basically various
variations on um shut up and calculate
and finally he said to me um why don't
you go talk to the philosophers they
asked this kind of meaningless question
and so I did and um and ended up going
to graduate school um in philosophy uh
studying philosophy of physics and then
somewhere along the line also began to
write novels so I feel like um The
Sciences the humanities and the Arts are
are I have an equal stake in all of them
and passionately love all of them um but
I think an awful lot about the
difference between the sciences and the
humanities and I and in particular one
Humanity uh one of the humanities
philosophy which I think is rather
different uh from the other Humanities
and I mostly I'm going to head that way
in my
comments there are two kinds of
questions uh that we wrestle with in
order to try to make sense of our of of
our lives uh make sense of everything uh
there are questions of what is and there
are questions of what matters um and
it's not as if these questions are
completely separate from each other uh
they have they uh have connections with
one another for example uh we can ask
whether it matters that we know what is
uh why should that really matter that we
know what is but we do you know we come
into this universe and we want to know
the ontological furniture what kind of
world is this uh what and which is also
a question of of what are
we
um sometime it didn't really begin in
the Greek world the roots are in the
Greek world but sometime around the 16
17th century uh we came up uh with a an
amazing conglomeration of different
cognitive
techniques uh that have helped us
discover what is um and
that
conglomeration of a priori mathematics
and observation Theory and
intuition is is called science science
is our best means of telling us what is
uh because
uh what science did uh uh develop it's
not just Intuition or a prior uh reason
or um or
observation uh science developed this
technique of getting reality getting
nature to answer us back when we're
getting it wrong this is incredible that
we came up with this and I very much
credit Galileo for this uh one of my one
of My Heroes um even though he was such
a platonist was Galileo uh that in one
of his letters he said that if my
critics weren't so stupid I could
persuade them through pure uh a priori
reason U but because they're so stupid I
have to perform experiments so we can be
very happy that uh Galileo's critics
were so stupid uh because this is an
amazing thing uh we come at you know our
our intuition
are very very faulty even the most basic
of our intuitions about space time
causality identity um and we have
developed this way of setting things up
so that when we you know reality gets a
chance uh to correct us oh so you think
simultaneity is absolute do you it seems
perfectly intuitively obvious to you
does it well we'll just see about that
right relativity Theory um
all sorts of all sorts of ways in which
our intuitions have been shown to be
false so when it comes to what is uh
science all the way of course I've just
given a philosophical um argument uh in
favor of that uh so that science in and
of itself often has to depend on
philosophical arguments uh I've just
given I I haven't really given the
argument but I'm uh implying scientific
realism that's a philosophical POS I it
takes an
argument
um okay uh so what are the humanities
good for well um in addition to just uh
knowing what is that world that we're
that we're in um there's this whole
inner world of
subjectivity uh that is extremely
important to us as as human beings it
matters to us it matters to us to know
what kind of world we live in
objectively and also this inner world
that we uh each of us individually um
inhabit the world as it is for us
colored with our memories our emotions
our aptitudes our intuitions
individually variable um that's all very
very interesting to us um and I think
for the most part the humanities are an
exploration of that inwardness as it's
informed by culture um and uh and and
other factors and it as it varies from
from Individual to individual we're
we're interested in that and we learn a
a lot about human nature uh uh by by uh
studying this we enrich our own maybe
that's a better way of putting we enrich
our own inner world uh through this
study of of of humanities um philosophy
I think is very different um that uh
philosophy uh you know in in the academy
is set up in such a way so that every
field has to belong to either the
Sciences the social sciences or the
humanities philosophy certainly isn't a
science uh and it's it's not
experimental it doesn't probe reality in
the way that that science is uh it
doesn't get reality to answer us back in
the way that uh science is do uh do it's
not a social scientist science so by
default it's a Humanity but it doesn't
really fit in there uh with with the
humanities it is not an exploration of
uh inner inner
subjectivity um my bumper sticker answer
to what philosophy is is that it is a
discipline um a technique uh that tries
to maximize coherence uh that tries to
maximize our various uh uh intuitions it
tries to maximize the coherence between
the scientific image um of the world uh
that our latest science gives us um and
other intuitions that we need in order
to live coherent lives uh it also tries
to maximize our um moral coherence there
are certain uh uh intuitions we have
moral intuitions come very naturally to
us uh in fact it's very very hard to
live one's life without committing uh
being committed to those certainly as
they apply to ourselves and our kin
probably uh the results of uh natural
selection what uh what what evolution
has has yielded to us but it's very hard
to give these things up um and
philosophy uh tries to see what other
things are implied by these intuition so
it's a in general a a way of trying to
make us more coherent uh Max Al coherent
trying to um uh actually I'm I'm going
to quote a philosopher here Wilfred sers
a 20th century philosopher wrote a very
good article was very helpful to me when
I was battling whether or not agonizing
whether or not to go on in physics or in
philosophy wrote something called
philosophy in the scientific image of
man um what he said is the aim of
philosophy abstractly formulated is to
understand how things in the broadest
possible sense of the term hang together
in the broadest possible sense of the
term um so there's maximi bringing it
all together remember philosophy does
have a technique it's called the
argument uh that's how we we don't have
experiments it's an argument what does
an argument do an argument is something
that explores consequences uh tries to
reconcile uh various aspects just goes
from Maximum consistency maximum
coherence um and uh and that's that's
somewhat different from from the
exploration of inwardness of the of the
other Humanities um I'm going to end
there did I ruffle your feathers not at
all oh okay uh all right thank you um
and Bob we'll move on to you well I I
For Better or Worse am a practitioner of
a much more pedestrian discipline uh
biology doesn't have any major laws
biology doesn't have the pretensions of
having profundities associated with it
uh biologists like myself are just
cartographers we're we're travel guides
and we're trying to figure out what's
been going on on this planet for the
last three and a half billion years
trying to peel away onion layer by onion
layer all of the rather arbitrary
decisions that were made during the
course of evolution the Rube Goldberg
like Contraptions that were cobbled
together with greater or lesser success
and that ultimately ended up up with the
life forms that we now have on the
planet and uh these uh solutions that
were arrived at were not pre-ordained by
any fundamental laws of physics they
just happened there were
contingencies if uh a a meteor had not
uh landed uh somewhere in the Yucatan 55
million years ago it could be that the
dinosaurs would still be Supreme and we
mamals wouldn't be here at all there was
no law of the universe that dictated
that we intelligent beings would work on
would walk on two legs and have two
hands and maybe even two eyes it just
happened that way uh Jim Carol as I've
discussed with him on occasion also to
the extent he puts on the historian's
hat also deals with contingencies like
for example what would early
Christianity have been like had the
temple in Jerusalem not been destroyed
in the year 70 and the Barba Revolution
uh not taking place in the year 130 uh
these kind of historical accidents of
real history are very much the same as
the historical accidents that Define the
way life has evolved on Earth uh and
they humble one and they make one uh
understand ultimately that people like
myself must describe what happened try
to understand what happened and be
humbled by the fact that the life on
this planet is infinitely complex and
that we could spend the next 20,000
years if we wish to do so describing the
different life forms that have Arisen
and trying to make sense of all this
when maybe there isn't any sense so uh I
I will not try any profundities here but
simply say that I'm just a travel
guide uh okay um thank you uh thank you
Bob um so to start things off it struck
me as I was listening to you all that um
we've divided this up into sciences and
the humanities um and it seems like
there potentially at least these two
other areas that um we're possibly uh
assuming belong in one or the other and
that's uh the Arts um and the social
sciences and I think part of the initial
discussion that arose um uh last spring
was um some of the tension between uh
literary Theory and producing literature
uh to sort of simplify it in that way um
so Alan I'll start with you how do you
see do you see the social sciences as
being part of the sciences and do you
see the Arts as being the creation of
art um and literature and music as being
part of the traditional
Humanities well I don't think that you
can lump all the social sciences
together the same way Rebecca said that
philosophy was not quite one of the
humanities
um I mean uh if you take economic for
example which I think is considered a
social science yeah well at MIT it is
yeah well well there's a huge range of
of of
styles and methods of doing economics
and some of it is very mathematical and
and the economists just do computer
models and they have mathematical models
and they test their models and
everything stays on the
computer uh
and and that is uh that that mimics the
sciences that mimics The Sciences as
long as there's some way that they can
do experiments uh to test the models so
so would would a difference there be
that they're not um reproducible in the
way that a traditional science
experiment would be because you can't go
back and run different economic models
on the world you can't run different
economic models on on the world you can
run different economic models on a given
set of starting a sun that might have a
random element a manlo element in it um
and then of course then there are
there's the Other Extreme end of
Economics that is
uh uh deals very much with with
populations
and might have a lot of similarities to
Sociology right so I think that there's
there's just too big a range of of of
branches and styles of the social
sciences um so I think the social
sciences can act like uh what we're
calling the Sciences or the physical
sciences or they can act more like the
humanities um Rebecca I think you have
something to say about that oh well you
know um there are all different
approaches in the physical sciences as
well I mean the way a an experimentalist
and a theoretical physicist operate are
very very differently and and the way
you know a biologist and a physicist or
a chemist I mean there are there are
differences uh within the physical
sciences as well I mean the social
sciences well yeah I consider them
science Sciences they are trying to test
things and uh they they run tests and
they're trying to uh you know it's it's
it's social groups that they're trying
to test uh or in the case of psychology
you know individuals but they are um
they are they're running tests and
trying to uh correct their intuitions
and so you know I consider them to be to
be Sciences um I mean the the advance in
the behavioral sciences and psychology
uh you know over our lifetime has just
been amazing I do not consider
psychology a science When I Was An
undergraduate um it's now you very much
very you know cognitive science
evolutionary psychology uh effective and
cognitive Neuroscience I mean it it's
this is these are Sciences um economics
there's still a lot of haziness because
we're we're dealing with with uh
psychology and there is there is a
psychology of of large groups and
there's a lot of uncertainty because of
the complexity of the systems there so
you know but I I think that they are
yeah they are going that way the method
it's empirical it's testing um and
they've made tremendous amount of of of
progress um what would you ask something
about the Arts uh well can we can come
back to that that's yeah no that's
that's great yeah Jim well I I'd like to
ask a a kind of dumb question really
which is even though the distinction
between the sciences and Humanities is
useful in many ways in terms of are
enabling us to sort out the Enterprises
involved in each isn't it also important
to pay attention to the way in which
it's a destructive
dichotomy sends us down a kind of Dead
End Road um maybe in both
instances wouldn't we be better off if
we were more
comfortable with a more um inclusive
category of knowing or knowledge I mean
in in a way that that was the point of
my starting point which was to go back
to the time before there were these
distinctions in the intellectual
Enterprise um and for me the issue is
what we mean by
knowing right and uh because I think
that we know whether in The Sciences or
in the humanities exactly in the same
way which is that we in in the phrase
that Allan was just using we create
models uh we
create uh experiments uh we create
narratives we create
images the intellect is a function of
the
imagination and one of our problems is
we imagine that the intellect and the
imagination are separate faculties of of
the human
person and the next thing you know art
and artists are expected to occupy a
separate category of being where the
disciplines of Hardcore intellectual
Enterprise don't apply right so that
feeling
justifies everything without being
submitted to the discipline of thought
which is the end of
art so and if we pay attention to the
way in which narrative art for example
the simple creation of a story what
Rebecca does when she writes a
novel uh has to be submitted to every
bit as rigorous a set of disciplines as
the most uh structured experiment that
Robert conducts in his laboratory
because it's they're both abound by the
same rules of knowing which goes back to
a a sense of this Enterprise that
predates the deadly Enlightenment
dichotomy
between uh rationality and emotional
life between well as it comes down to us
between the sciences and the humanities
between the hard sciences and the soft
humanties which uh are denigrated by
definition of the contrast with the more
rigorous Sciences well I think it's and
and we can circle around back to this
but I think possibly or at least one of
the ways that I can of the difference
there is that while writing a novel or
um a poem or producing a piece of art
requires uh attention to both the
discipline and discipline um there
aren't the same rules across the board
that there that there would be in
conducting a scientific experiment so
you could have four people writing
novels who all are adhering to very
different Notions of what it means to
produce that but let's let's maybe come
back to that um Bob one thing I I I
wanted to ask you about because I know
Allen's feelings on the subject um is uh
your feelings about about ambiguity in
results um one of the things that really
generated some of the excitement or some
of the attention in the spring was
Allen's um statement I think that
scientists don't like ambiguity uh I
think you said it makes them it makes
them uncomfortable maybe you just said
they don't like it um and so he said it
again right yes right uh but and so I'm
curious about in your own work how you
feel about ambiguity which and I'm sure
you must get that in results all the
time all the time yes well I feel I
deprecated my my discipline by saying it
was only a higher form of stamp
collecting right because the fact I
thought you were I thought you were a
travel a travel guide yes but the fact
of the matter is in order to make very
descriptors of how life is cobbled
together one needs to use very rigorous
logic one needs reproducible results and
one can say UNAM I can say in an
unambiguous fashion that we hate
ambiguity that is to say we are only
comfortable and we only sleep well at
night when we think we found out
something that we can assert is
unambiguously true and that other people
can find to be true it may not be a
profound result in terms of the whole
history of life on the planet or in
terms of curing cancer but for that
little particle of observation and
conclusion we make that it will stand
the test of time and it will still be
true 10 20 and 30 years from now it may
be elaborated upon but it's tress is not
uh in any way contingent on the way that
certain people might interpret what we
have found and so uh to the extent Allen
said that scientists hate ambiguity he
properly characterized us and so do do
do you and and Allan you can jump in
here too if you'd like um do you feel
like that uh limits the questions that
you ask
definitely that that we ask yeah yes it
does in the following sense that if
somebody in my laboratory proposes to do
an experiment and I ask them what kind
of result are you going to get and they
forecast a range of possible results I'd
say well which of those results will
lead you to an unambiguous conclusion
will allow you to say solidly this is
true or this is not true and if they
can't propose a eventual Avenue that
will lead them to some unambiguous
conclusion and I'm not talking about
conclusions about the whole history of
life on the planet but even the
structure of a small m molecule right if
they can't uh Converge on some
unambiguous result I'll look at them and
be a little bit dismissive at least in
my physiognomy as far as the uh the uh
as far as how seriously I should take
them and and their proposed trajectory
so does that mean that um I guess what I
what I what I want to ask is does that
mean that there are questions that might
lead you to results that could lead to
to different avenues that would give you
unambiguous answers yes that you're not
asking because some of the intermediate
steps along the way would be would be
would have more ambiguity in them could
well be but people have to make a living
and uh and when I say that I don't mean
to trivialize uh my craft but the fact
of the matter is they will say about
this person or that person well he
claimed this and he claimed that and
he's claimed three other things and
nobody can really reproduce that work
maybe he's right maybe he's wrong that's
not a credible scientist a credible
biologist now it could be that that the
absolutely unambiguous results that he
or she converges on uh may be trivial
and totally uninteresting but at least
they're solid right uh that person also
doesn't command a lot of respect if all
they do is to gather up the tri solid
information scarcia of Life on this
planet and there are many of
those Recca did do you want to yeah yeah
well um sorry I've been on book tour and
I'm just totally losing my voice
um one place in which I find um a
tremendous amount of ambiguity among
scientists is in um their description of
what it is that they're doing when
they're doing science um and so for
example
the um the uh the answers you've given
um there are the answer I often get from
scientists is a sort of Carl po perian
view is of that uh you know we're I'm
not in fact I've been I've had it
objected when I say that science
discovers what is um a strict paparian
will say and many scientists are strict
paparian will say no um we've only
discovered what isn't uh what we're
we're trying to do in science is to
falsify it's conjecture and reputation
right uh it nothing is going to stand up
to the test of time that's that's that
is the definition of of science it's
falsifiable um well I uh for me uh this
popian ism is amusing yeah because it
makes no sense well it's interest but
there is ambiguity all I want to say is
that there is sort of uh ambiguity in in
terms of what it is uh that one's
actually doing and when one's doing
science so I'm just reading actually um
Stephen Hawkins latest book The Grand
Design um and I'm guessing it's Stephen
Hawkin is not reading your latest book
because what did he say in 2011
philosophy is dead right philosophy is
dead and then he so that's actually um
in this book and it's a maybe second or
third uh page and then he proceeds to do
philosophy philosophy of science to say
what it is that philosop that science is
doing and he has a kind of
neocon uh view but not only is he doing
uh philosophy there but he is um doing
it not very well he he contradicts
himself sometimes he's talks as if he's
a scientific realist sometimes he talks
as if he's not a scientific realist um
but there is complete ambiguity when it
comes to what is it uh that one is
actually doing when one's doing science
because in fact um science itself can
answer that question you're already
going into the realm of philosophy of
science when you do that and that is
full of ambiguity so although in what
what what's interesting to me is I can
get people who are collaborating in on
their work they all agree on the science
they're collaborators and they
completely disagree on what it is that
they're doing when they're doing science
are they describing reality is it just a
model that's not science no it's not
it's philosophy I mean that's exactly my
point if Professor Weinberg you know
finds a gene that causes cancer and he's
able to manipulate it you know at some
point in the future they may be a a drug
or a method of using that to cure
cancer if you ask him to say what he's
doing yeah and uh he has a bunch of
different explanations and somebody else
may have a diff a different set of
explanations about what he's doing those
explanations of what he's doing is not
science the thing that he did is science
but the discussion of what it is is
philosophy that's what's my point well I
I this really makes me want to make my
point again which is that distinction is
there's something problematic about that
distinction because I don't about the
distinction between the philosophy of
science and science yes or as I take
Rebecca's way of putting it the
distinction between those who ask what
is and those who ask what does it
mean and I think if you if you assign
those questions to separate projects
and separate people and separate
Enterprises and separate systems of
funding separate academic uh
distinctions something inhuman is
happening that's my intuition I I can't
say more than rais this question uh I
mean we can all think of uh and I as I
hear Robert describe his commitment to
the question what is I hear also in the
way you
you pose it a a a firm commitment to the
question what does it mean you may not
you may not put that forward as your
question but I hear that in your and
you're the kind of scientist who asks
what is as a way of asking what does it
mean I I won't deny that but I won't
move back from the first step which is
is there any kind of objective
reality uh if you let's say I'm a cog
grapher let's call that a science and I
describe the shape of the continents and
the shape of the continents is the
consequence of a whole series of
contingencies geological contingencies
over the last four and a half billion
years are these uh are the maps of of
the world are they real are they only uh
artifacts of our perception and in the
same sense um is my description of the
structure of a gene or the structure of
a cell or a protein is is that a reality
or is it just a matter of my own
subjective interpretation and I'm very
reluctant to inter to embrace the second
idea the second alternative um I it's
your subjective interpretation yes but
why are
those why can't it be a
reality in being your
subjective
perception why why do we need
this it sounds almost platonic to me
this radical div divide between what's
real and what we perceive so the map of
Spain is not Spain where there's an old
saying that Maine lobstermen are fond of
saying to people from a way like me when
they help us off a rock you can't get
the chart is not the
sea the chart is not the sea the travel
you're a travel guide who makes Maps the
map is not the geography but in a way it
is because once we enter the geography
we perceive it its reality according to
the map we have in our brain but
interpretation in other words is the way
we human beings interact with what's
real are are those but I I distance
myself from the from embracing this
whole subjectivity because I have the
illusion that certain truths that people
like me find now will be found by
totally unrelated people people coming
from different different backgrounds
using different instruments and
different scientific strategies 10 20
and 100 years from now that's the
pretentious world I live in uh and and
if I didn't think that I wouldn't want
to be doing this because I wouldn't want
to make everything that we discover
contingent on what happens to be the
ideological favorite view of biology
this year or next year right and and it
it seems like there are there are
potentially two different things that
that are being discussed here one is
this um dichotomy between asking
questions of what is and what does it
mean and then there's the issue of
perception and how our individual and
human perception affects all of our
knowledge and everything that affects
both of those questions and it seems
like you don't need to get into the
issues of perception to look at what is
and what does it mean as two different
two two sort of fundamentally different
questions that lead to two fundamentally
different
fields well again going back to the
abstract question of what do we mean by
knowing and I take it my my
philosophical ground my assumption which
is pre Ral I can't prove it is
that we we we
know by
imagining We Know by creating what
aquinus calls a
fantasm of reality and we the fantasm
stands between us and the reality
there's a mediation that's going on and
that mediation is the place of meaning
and while Robert you surely the
experiments you're conducting now can be
repeated in another time in another
culture but I would I would argue
without a lot of authority that the
meaning necessarily will be different
the fact the fact of the perception in
the experiment may be identical if if
you've done it right it will be
but what it means to those scientists
will be different from what it means to
you and that and I don't think you get
knowledge until you match the the the
fact of the object known with the knower
and the knower is always conditioned
again you know I'm stuck with aquinus
aquinus is wonderful
airism all knowledge comes to the
receiver in the mode of the receiver not
in the mode of what's
known uh so you started your anecdote by
going to a professor and asking about
interpretation you said I can't give you
the exact quote maybe you remember it
how do I interpret this and that was the
you that was the moment of the end of
communication with the professor who
vanished you to philosophy but
interpretation is the issue
interpretation in your work has to be
the issue Robert Rebecca do you I think
Rebecca has something to say um well I
mean actually what I wanted out of
physics uh was to tell me what is what
is right what kind of world are we
living in and he wasn't willing to to
use at least quantum mechanics in those
days in in that way uh it's different
now actually um but um so you want you
were looking for what is and not what
does it mean and he yeah just because it
mattered to me to know what is right so
I mean yes these things are you know
there it's human and I totally agree
with you you know the the false
dichotomy between imagination and
intellect and between uh intellect and
and um emotion this is this is false and
and certainly any kind of dichotomy in
terms of valuation what which one is is
more important uh than the other um but
um what knowledge is what a philosopher
think defines knowledge
is is a Justified true belief right um
and but the way different questions can
be justified using different means it's
interesting to me that you keep going
back to aquinus because of course
aquinus is pre-scientific I mean the the
he he was trying to uh he was working
within the Aristotelian system this was
uh
Aristotle uh uh it was a purely
speculative system it was using certain
intuitions and and and and carrying them
for Ward uh but it was not it was not
science and um it was not trying to
probe reality to answer us back uh to
correct any of our intuitions um it's
amazing we we landed on this technique I
mean it it
aristotelianism with with its thology
had a lot of uh years going and we
didn't really get anywhere uh and then
you know man we wed it together together
uh
mathematics observation certain of our
our observations we can um abstract
certain aspects of it Galileo called
those the primary qualities and and and
translate them into mathematical
language the book of nature is written
in the language of mathematics right uh
Galileo said and then because his
critics were so stupid testing I mean
that is the key thing a the stupid
critics right let's hear it stupidity um
so not all questions can be submitted to
this to this methodology and and you
know and these questions about what it
means to be human and and um these are
not questions that could be submitted
it's amazing we we we came up with this
technique we've gotten as far as we're
doing String Theory that's amazing that
with these hunter gatherer brains we
managed to this yeah I mean pays off we
didn't come up with it by accident it
pays off B did you have say Tak us far I
I just want to say one thing and keep in
mind that when I when the things that I
do I'm talking about my discipline uh I
I have the Hope or the the pretense that
uh other people 10 20 and 50 years from
now will find the same thing but there's
even a more pretentious uh and ambitious
uh thought there and that is if somebody
were to come down from Mars and had the
tools of investigation that we did we do
but had obviously a quite different kind
of brain than we do
this entity whatever it would be would
also Converge on the same set of
conclusions about the reality of the
physical world and in that sense if that
if that pretention is is correct of mine
for example then the whole intervention
of the human mind becomes almost a
historical artifact of how One LED found
something rather than a an important
constituent of its reality and but
that's not a pretention of yours it's a
pretention of science yes right right um
or at least as we call it sometimes the
hard Sciences right uh yeah uh let me
just uh put in a word of defense for
aquinus
here without without aquinus no
Galileo I'd say without Plato no Galileo
PL uh Galileo was drenched in the tus uh
which was the one uh the one uh dialogue
of Plato that was taught well I wouldn't
say without I wouldn't say only aquinus
but what I mean by that is aquinus lifts
up the absolute importance of what he
calls sensory
knowledge which is a rescue from
Plato uh for whom knowledge is
essentially abstraction if if we really
want to get into philosophy we could say
without anything that happened in the
past the future as we know it wouldn't
exist but uh that's probably a whole
other um forum um Alan there is there's
one thing before I open it up that I
want to make sure I ask you about and
that's um when you are engaged in these
two different practices uh in physics
and in writing fiction um do you go into
that with not fundamentally different
questions that you're asking but is the
drive that leads you um to create and to
uh uh to explore and investigate and
produce in these two dramatically
different fields does that feel like it
comes from the same
place in 30 seconds or less please well
the the creative moment which is one of
the main motivations is it's like a drug
um that feels to me exactly the same and
so how would you describe the creative
moment in
physics well I'll describe it when
you uh you've been struggling with the
problem and uh you
suddenly see it in a different way you
you have a different perspective and you
you see the solution to the
problem uh and in that moment where you
you have this experience um you're
totally free of your
ego um your ego comes in strongly later
on maybe when you're deciding where you
should publish the results and so on but
but but in that moment where
you're
finding out something new that you
didn't know before maybe that no one
knew before it's an eg- free state it's
a state that's where you
don't know where you are or you don't
know what time it is you're just
understanding something it's a very
beautiful experience and I I think uh
I've had that uh I've been lucky enough
to have it a few times in
science do you experience the same thing
when you're when you're Crea fiction yes
and so where at what point does it come
it sounds like it comes at the end of
the process almost or near the end of
the process when you're when you're uh
looking at a problem in physically well
I think you have to have a prepared a
prepared mind in either in any of these
disciplines to have this creative
experience um I did a a a survey about
10 years ago of great discoveries in
science in the 20th century in all
different fields and I found your book
The discoveries yes and I found that in
no cases were the great discoveries made
by
amateurs there there were some cases
where scientists found uh things
unexpectedly but in all cases the
scientists had done their
homework they had developed the craft of
the tool of of the trade they had the
knowledge they knew where the frontier
was uh and that's what I mean by the
prepared mon right um I think we're
going to open it up to to questions uh I
will take the the uh I I might grab
things back um during this but for the
moment we're going to open up to
questions I would love to start with uh
Mary Fuller um who uh as I mentioned
before was a big part why we're all here
thanks so much Seth and thanks to the
panelists and especially Allan for
putting this together it's really a
pleasure to get to continue this
conversation a little bit more
expansively um I want to say two things
and I guess the first one is that I feel
like we uh it's this is a discussion
that I feel is perhaps not getting as
much traction as it might because we're
operating at a very high level of
abstraction and not defining terms very
well so you know if you take a term like
ambiguity I think that perhaps it's
being used in the sense of vagueness I
think about it rather differently um
from the perspective of literature I
think of ambiguity as something where uh
there are multiple a set of values that
are possible
simultaneously and that it's a device or
a situation that one could describe in
very rigorous ways and that has
particular affordances do do you mean
there there are multiple sets of values
that that there that there may be
multiple values that are possible that
one can't decide between you know and
this is the kind of thing that people in
literature sort of study and
characterize and are interested in um
and and I'll just say one word about
ambiguity the reason that this came into
the discussion I think between Allan and
myself was that a colleague here in
Material Science said to me you know the
humanities is are value because valuable
because they teach our students to deal
with ambiguity and you can't be a good
scientist unless you can reckon with it
now I should have asked him to
characterize more exactly what he meant
by ambiguity um but unfortunately he
didn't and he's not here so I can't
speak for him um but another thing that
struck me is that uh you know the
sciences and the humanities I think in
this discussion are being characterized
in what to me is a somewhat peculiar way
I would characterize them differently
it's such a big question right but if if
you take uh the pendulum is representing
science right and the sort of you know
something like Dart saying what do I
know is the humanities then you get
things that are very very different but
to me it's interesting to think about
the things that are in the middle of the
SP
that are something more like craphy or a
history of the universe and I was struck
Alan that you sort of bracketed
cosmology is not being one of the
sciences that you were going to talk
about um because there are many things
that one wants to know about what is
that involve the past that are not
repeatable that do fall within the
domain of Science and perhaps that's why
I find cosmology and planetary science
so intellectually congenial you know
because they're they're like the work
that I do um which is fairly historical
but even if I put on the non-historical
hat I would say that for instance an
aesthetic object is one of the things
that is and a lot of my practice is to
describe that object in ways that are
fairly empirical um not to sort of to to
sit down and start having ideas about it
often I don't know how to have ideas
until I describe it until I characterize
it very accurately um now that's
completely unlike setting up a pendulum
and making a repeatable experience
experiment but when I have when I've
made a rigorous description of the
aesthetic object and then I might form a
hypothesis about it the way that I test
that hypothesis is to say how much of
this how many of these connections how
many of the things that exist in this
poem become more meaningful if on this
hypothesis right and so you know I'm not
that's not science um but it's that's
what I think of as the humanities that's
the humanities that I practice I it's
not a Humanities of sort of what is
inside my head right it is a Humanities
of my encounter with the object that's
outside me and I think that um a
historian would probably say something
fairly similar um so if we set you know
um perhaps versions of field science um
or historical science let's call it next
to other versions that the humanity is
like history we might be having a
different conversation Mary I actually
have a question for you so would you
describe what you do is
fundamentally um Looking Backward in the
sense that you're looking at what is
already there and so is that possibly a
a one useful way to make a distinction
that in science we're trying to um uh
describe the world as it might be in
terms of we want something to be
reproducible throughout the future and
in the humanities we're looking at
things that have already happened and
only things that have already
happened well I'm I'm not sure that
everybody body would agree with that
description of the humanities probably
true you're not sure that every with the
description of the humanities as as
being about the past okay well so then
I'm open to hearing other uh uh other
ideas but is I mean does anyone on the
panel have a notion of the humanities as
um something other than an
interpretation of reality as we have
already known
it an analy is contemporary culture as
well the humanities I mean art is being
produced um even as we speak and uh um
you know it's often there is a uh you
know the humanities are dealing with
that as well I'm really interested what
you say about ambiguity um because um I
mean actually in my two hats is working
as a philosopher and working as a
novelist I think about um if if you
scientists don't like ambiguity
analytical philosophers detest it uh
right it is we we make a a fetish out of
clarity maybe because we're dealing with
such murky issues and so it's so very
important to be as clear as you possibly
can um and it's interesting to me when
I'm writing a novel how and it it's hard
actually because the part of me that
that detests ambiguity has to be laid to
rest a little bit um when you're
creating a work you know when you're
creating art um there is a intentional
um ambiguity or or porousness maybe I
you can't fill in all the details
because what you're trying to do it
seems to me um is to create a a deep and
Rich experience in some unknown people
out there right um and that they have to
somehow be able to move into what you've
created there this Matrix that you've
created there of with their own
experiences their own subjectivity um
and and uh you know and and create their
own experiences and so there has to be
this
porousness um and and openness so that
they can that they can move in so it's a
it's a you know it's a thing it's it's
knowing you know what you you to provide
and what to leave out and when I was a
very new novelist um I would often be
horrified to hear what a reader would
make of my work right and you know oh I
loved your book you know it was all
about blah blah blah no what no it
wasn't about that at all how could you
Poss last thing I was thinking of um
that's because you know I was coming
from The Sciences and philosophy where
you don't you know you're trying to lay
things out and then um you know I
realized well no this is in fact what
you have to do if if they're able to
move in and create their own experience
um even though it's nothing that I
thought about um that's one of the major
differences between um you know being a
scientist or philosopher and being being
a an artist so I think that you know
sort of cultivated
intentional uh ambiguity is part of the
art of of being of being a writer um
that that actually might be a sort of
better way to describe what I was
getting at which is um thinking of the
humanities as an interpretive discipline
as opposed to uh an empirical discipline
um Chris introduce yourself and sure
thank you my name is uh Chris Peterson I
uh work in teach and research here um so
we've heard a pretty consistent
definition of the Sciences tonight which
I try to position somewhere in this
space of uh creating progressively more
stable and coherent descriptions of some
external world but I don't know that
we've heard a great definition of the
humanities or specifically the human
character that's inside the humanities
and what that means and maybe the most
consistent thing I've heard articulated
by the various people in the panel is
this thing about ambigu ambiguity
whatever that means although it seemed
to mean a lot about unpredictability and
there's been something about uh Humanity
being cefin with unpredictability at
least in the Christian um tradition that
you know James Carol has been talking
about since at least the time of the
fall right so you've got you know
interactions with natural uh actors like
humans and snakes and unpredictable
things happens and that's what gives you
a fundamentally human character but we
also used to give all sorts of
essentially human agency to non-human
actors like the sea you know in the sun
um because we didn't yet understand what
they did but as soon as science has come
in and made them predictable we now view
those unpr problematically as within the
domain of Science and if that's the case
is human just another word for what
science cannot yet predict and if that's
true how useful is it as a meaning F
conceptual
category who wants to tackle
that you you may have stumped the panel
well I I would offer a a simple thought
about it which what is a human being I
that's embedded in part of what you what
you said and I I would suggest a human
being is an imag making
creature and I I would see that
describing both the Enterprise of
Science and the enter of what we're
calling the humanities here imag making
creatures and I speaking certainly as no
scientist but I understand science as a
process of image
making and I don't accept the
distinction you just made between the
interpretive discipline and the
empirical discipline because I think I'm
arguing the empirical discipline has to
be interpretive and we interpret by
virtue of the images we make or the
stories we tell the narratives we create
experience is chaotic and without order
the imagination is the human faculty of
creating or imposing order we put a
beginning a middle and an end on chaotic
experience we create a narrative a story
and it has meaning for us and I see that
as the Enterprise of the laboratory as M
as much as of the poet's
workbench um Jim aren't and and let me
just finally say this activity is
inevitably ambiguous because an image is
never actually and fully identical with
the thing it images so there's a
built-in ambiguity to this Enterprise
whether it's Humanities or science sorry
Robert well aren't you really saying
that humanity is about the human mind
and and and soul uh and the vagaries
that flow from that whereas science is
is about the outside world that exists
independent of what kind of soul and
mind we have it's there uh where as
humanity is exploring everything that
flows from our own internal human
idiosyncrasies so the humanities are
also responding to the outside world
every bit as much so that when you get a
great novel uh War and Peace about the
invasion of Russia is very much the
outside world that is the subject of the
novel it's it's certainly that the
interior experience of those who undergo
that invasion is Central but it's very
much the World At Large that being
responded to well our our internal
experience is always you know partly a
response to to to theide because we're
embodied beings yeah okay but but but in
fact you know I mean the humanities are
about what it's like to be a human uh
what it uh is like to to have a human
life uh including that you know the
subjectivity the inner World which is
partly a response to one's own character
but also uh in interaction with with
with events that are going on and
including interaction with um uh what
we're finding out about science uh Allan
and I both like to write novels uh that
have um that are about discovering
scientific truths and and and what that
means in a human life uh but it is I
mean to live a human life is to to to
occupy the Spheres of of meaning and
mattering uh we occupy different
mattering Maps right different things
matter to us um and this is um this
actually this idea of a mannering map
was an idea that I came up with in a
novel uh tried to make it pretty precise
and then many decades later I discovered
that um it had taken on a life of its
own including a scientific life of its
own that it's uh been used in um in uh
behavioral economics so if you Google
matter in that you will get so many hits
many more hits than you'll get if you
Google me even though it was my term
because it has been adapted El was
proposed in a novel is actually been
adapted as a theoretical construct in
behavioral economics um so but anyway I
mean it's it is this this thing you know
it's it's a world of mattering it's a
human world and and an exploration of
that including um you know our
interactions with with the external
world including you know uh the
world as it's described by science
because that matters to us that's part
of our interpretation of what it means
to be human but B I I want to Circle
back really quickly to something you
said when you were talking about
Martians coming down um and having the
same tools that we did they would get
the same results and it seems like one
distinction here is that even if
martians came down and had literature
and then experienced um uh Russia and
they still might not produce War and
Peace in in fact it would they probably
would not produce war in peace is that
sort of what we're talking about here in
terms of yeah and and I would say that
that war in peace and it was the War of
1812 was it not that was being described
was also one of the multiple things that
flows out of the soul and the vagaries
of the human mind out of the the soul of
uh and mind of Napoleon and and uh of
the Zar and of the Russian people and of
the French people and all the entire
flow of European history and all of
those things are secondary tertiary and
quaternary consequences of The Human
Experience but not of any fixed truths
of the physical
world as opposed to what you're up to is
that what you mean yeah yeah I'm not
saying what I'm up to is any better but
it is different yes hi my name is Chris
Meyer and I think my question follows on
the on the previous question fairly
consequently um first of all props to
the destructive dichotomy and I think we
um are perhaps overestimating the
dichotomy and a couple of reasons why
followed by a question ambiguity seems
to me ineluctably present in both Realms
right we have goodles theorem that tells
us we either have contradictions or
incompletions we have the uncertainty
principle we have Stuart cosman's work
that says you cannot preate the
configuration of a complex system uh so
science has proven in many levels that
we cannot know everything and perhaps
it's just that people who like to
explore ambiguity are doing things we
call humanists and people who like to
avoid ambiguity are making their living
as as Bob pointed out doing the things
where those ambiguities don't affect our
ability to to keep the airplane up
um so they share that that tolerance for
ambiguity although they may deal with it
in different ways and keep in mind that
people like like me don't pretend we can
know everything yeah all we pretend is
that we can know a finite number of
things with great solidity and lack of
ambiguity well and you have a different
objective from somebody who's exploring
the human our our objectives are almost
irrelevant okay so here's my my question
is it's been since we stumbled on this
method the scientific method it's been a
lot easier to make a laboratory for the
physical sciences than for social
science or humanism you know you could
you could imagine a a continent with
thousands of Truman Show domes in it and
testing different people in the same
Dome perhaps but it's not practical or
hasn't been but here we live in a time
where Quantified Self is happening where
all kinds of individual data is
appearing where we have the power to
deal with that data where we've learned
to do agent-based models of that create
emergent properties in societies
including models of civil violence which
can't today pre uh predict the War of
1812 but seem to predict the extinction
of the anastasi Indians can you imagine
that it's just that our study of of what
we think of as The Human Condition is
way behind because we don't have the
Laboratories and we are developing
better Laboratories to do experiments
and of course recent evidence suggests
that a lot of scientific experiments
don't have the replicability we thought
they did but where we can do experiments
test for replicability and and
expand uh the ability to understand
human beings in a more scientific way
that's my
question I it I mean does does that
question get into um a a moral issue of
of what you can actually do to humans to
find results I mean you couldn't you
couldn't do a trim and show scenario
unless you consider Facebook experiments
on people to be inhumane yeah right you
might but I mean I no but well you don't
have to have active experiments on
people to do to learn things from um
information about Behavior at the
individual level I I think that
experiments on people independent of
whether they're Humane or inhumane are
intrinsically flawed because the
complexity of the human mind and its
various manifestations is so enormous
that we have no idea how to begin to
reduce isn't that what we said about the
mind of God before
Galileo well it could be the case that
100 years from now we will be we'll be
able to speak more about the variability
and the and the multiple independent
variables of the human mind with greater
Precision but now it's vastly beyond our
ability even to discuss it in any
intelligent way and so I I uh I hear
with Amusement the notion that uh
if only we had better tools and better
Laboratories we could reduce uh the
human mind and its workings to some kind
of predictable processes because I don't
believe it yeah but um you know there
are many people who would make the
argument that um uh the advance of um of
the behavioral sciences has has um is
already shedding light on the uh typical
subjects of the humanities that
evolutionary psychology
um is offering uh arguments about how we
evolved our moral systems um there's um
evolutionary Aesthetics there's even
neuro athetics uh that is that is uh
giving um studying what the brain is
doing which parts of the brain are being
um excited in fmri machines when one is
undergoing various different kinds of
aesthetic experiences um I mean so there
are there are in fact scientists
especially in um evolutionary psychology
who would claim um look you know we
really do have light to shed on on the
humanities on the typical subjects of
the humanities and um it's really been U
people in the humanities who have kind
of resisted this are are you going to
colonize it's not enough that you're
taking up all the real estate on these
campuses you're you going to colonize us
as well right with your big data and
your and your scientific theories so you
know I do think there is still room for
this kind of
interpretive uh
hermeneutics uh that uh you know the
humanities um cultivates that it's a
different it's a different kind of
discipline but there there definitely is
um communication between the sciences
and and Humanities and I I think that's
that's really good I think there should
be more I think the uh the advances in
the behavioral sciences do have
something to to to shed some light we
don't have to do any nefarious experim
experimenting uh well some Neer
experimenting but thanks yeah hi uh my
name is Joseph saring I'm a researcher
here uh in my brief academic travels so
far I have come to perceive what I would
call a troubled relationship between the
academy and activism uh and my guess
would be that that has something to do
with uh of course varying by field uh a
different understanding of the nature of
objectivity uh and I'm wondering if any
of you would like to comment that or
shoot me down or have any other ideas
well tell us what you mean by
activism um that's a complicated
question uh I think well is there a
specific scenario that you're is is
there a situation that you're thinking
of or referring to uh not one specific
uh I think I'm considering most within
the emerging parts of sociology and
gender studies and race studies a
tendency to be more um po politically
and socially active uh as well as
developing new knowledge uh and I think
I find some some disagreement with that
principle from other approaches and
Fields I I guess one question to ask is
to what extent are different kinds of
activism driven by pre-existing
ideological preconceptions rather than
by some pretense of objectively uh
analyzing the situation and saying that
this situation dictates one thing or
another and uh in fact activism is
indeed the perception of activism is
strongly tainted by the notion that many
activists For Better or Worse really
come to the solution of a problem
carrying already a large amount of
ideological baggage even before they
became as it were
activists I mean certainly on the issue
of global warming um you know there has
been activism among scientists I mean
scientists have have have stood up and
wanted to you know have offered their
expertise uh not ideological expertise
but scientific uh and uh you know and
and it's a kind of activism uh and I
don't know if that's what you what you
have in mind but but it's founded on on
objectivity Jim well I I'm glad you
brought that up Rebecca because it does
strike me that I I'm mystified myself
that the
activism of scientists who have helped
us understand the threat of global
warming has been so limited they the
testimony of scientists is
powerful but there's nothing equivalent
to the profound Embrace of activism that
we saw among scientists at a crucial
moment in the Cold War here the union of
concerned scientists 45 years ago the
scientists on both sides of the Iron
Curtain who began actually to carry the
banner they were the leading activists
in raising questions about the arms race
arms reduction the entire arms reduction
regime a lot of it a lot of the activist
impulses centered among scientists here
was I I would argue and I I think it's a
ready case can be made that was the most
single most important fact that enabled
the Cold War to turn and it was
scientists on both sides of the Iron
Curtain who shed their shyness about
activism and became radical activists I
don't know is that in the background of
the question you're asking yes I think
so Alan did you have a thought there did
you have a thought or were you
just you don't need to have a thought
I'm not trying to put you on the spot no
I'll I'll leave the time to the audience
okay yeah um my name is David rush I'm a
retired professor at Tufts spent my life
as a an epidemiologist and a scientist
there were two things that I'd like to
comment on one was the sense of
Revelation that Alan Lightman described
because that's exactly how it worked for
me uh I had about one good idea a year
and I was some years I missed but you
know and I didn't go into the laboratory
Sciences because when I was taking
quantitative analysis I had to scrape my
preparations off the floor and I I just
figured I would do something different
so I became an epidemiologist I use
statistics I use I have to deal with
human populations I have to deal with
multivaried
situations and what pref one of the
there are two stages of that Revelation
one is what question am I interested in
and the second stage is how can I answer
that question and I would challenge dror
Weinberg Professor Weinberg say how you
choose your questions in my own field I
I see so many pieces of stupid research
where obvious answered questions are
reans answered over and over and over
again because they're obvious and
they're easy but but I think you and the
Martian might have very different
experiences generating the questions I
suspect he wouldn't work on the same
problems you do although you might have
gotten the same answers if you had
proposed the same questions I don't
doubt for a moment that your work is
replicable but why do you do your work
what is it that makes you want to answer
the question you asked if it's not
something to say about cancer that's
very activist from my point of view well
keep in mind I I didn't say that the uh
let's not ascribe to me something I
didn't say I I didn't say that the
Martian would necessarily be interested
in examining the same issue or question
that I had
what I did say is if they happen to
examine the same question they would
Converge on the same uh um answer uh
however addressing your point more
directly for me the greatest difficulty
and the greatest challenge in training
young scientists is to impart and
instill in them a taste for what is uh
interesting and conceptually
consequential uh and has ramifications
for much work of others and what is
Trivial and simply a data data gathering
for its own sake
and there is a great distinction there
and to my mind uh to the extent that I
have the the pretense or the hope of
training really good young scientists
who are creative and Innovative it is
impressing on them the critical
importance of constantly asking
themselves why am I doing this is this
an important question or is this one
which gives me satisfaction for the sole
purpose for the for the sole reason that
I'm just Gathering more and more uh
almost uninterpretable information so of
course I agree with you completely I
think that creative element though is
not one that one can describe quite as
as as securely as the result that arises
from answering the question you're
absolutely right okay so we're of one
mind it's clear it it's clear that the
the person missing on this panel is the
Martian who would been able to answer a
lot of these questions yes I thanks a
lot for to all of you for being here um
I'm Daniel gross I'm a journalist um so
we've talked a lot about the or we've
tried to gra grapple with the nature of
knowledge we haven't spoken much about
the transmission of knowledge um in
concrete terms and maybe a way to to Poe
that in a less abstract way is um what
did we learn from Shakespeare or some
literary figure and how does that
compare to what we learned from Darwin
say and just a really quick anecdote to
maybe push back um on the notion that
science can be transmitted in a in an
uncomplicated way
um I knew a student of biology who
learned uh the structure of cells with
diagrams and on the exam he received a
picture of a cell and none of the
students were able to identify the
mitochondria or the nuclei because they
had they had learned with images and had
never encountered what is
so does anyone want to tackle
Shakespeare vers Darwin I mean if it's
true that a great work of art
Shakespeare produced many of them um is
uh you know is going to vary uh with
each reader because they bring their own
subjectivity to merge with what
Shakespeare has created um and and uh um
it was funny because I was just today uh
at the at the gym talking to somebody
about King Lear and um and we had very
very different experiences we had both
discuss exactly right in in Cambridge
Massachusetts yes um and so um you know
we we because of what both of us are
going through right now in our lives we
both had turned to King leer but we're
going through something different and so
we were reading different things uh we
were reading two different plays um but
what we can study is um Shakespeare's
techniques I mean how he was able to do
this what do we learn from Shakespeare
well we learn how to create these
amazing um works of art I mean the kinds
of techniques that he used is the kind
of openness and porousness and ambiguity
that he cultivates uh so that you know
all of these hundreds of years later two
people you know can sit in the gym and
find themselves there find answers there
um but it won't but they're not going to
be the same because they're not the same
experiences um in the way that when I
read you know Newton um I know what he
was saying uh you know or when I read a
a mathematical proof you know if I
uclid I know what he was saying there
you know that kind of precision um and
so although the Take On the Origin of
Species um it seems very possible that
two people in a gym in Cambridge uh
could have a conversation about that and
it could mean very different things to
the two of
them yeah but the the ultimate salian
points that are distilled from the
Origin of Species would ultimately
converge if you pushed the logic to its
extreme do a relatively small number of
reasonably well articulated uh
principles um it's not as if uh the
conclusions from from
Darwin would or or should be shaped by
one's personal experience human being
but you could read On the Origin of
Species and come away from that um with
a different sense of wonder at the
universe and not any certain me that not
any more sophisticated understand not
you could come away not actually
understanding any of the specifics of
what Darwin was talking about in terms
of evolutionary theory and still have it
be a very profound experience yep that's
a literary experience right right right
of a scientific work we might read it
very very differently because you know
in his day to say what he was saying to
be expunging design from the universe
was a very different experience uh than
it is for us in the in the 21st century
you know it was a a radical and you know
anti uh many of the firm beliefs and you
know so you know it was certainly a
different experience but but but the the
aspects of the theory um yeah I mean to
understand the theory is to understand
what Darwin was saying what he was
asserting and the grounds on which he
was saying
it yeah hi I'm Josh Kohl's from the
Oxford internet Institute um just like I
say this is my first MIT event I've been
to and uh it set the bar pretty high for
the level of sort of insight and
conversation which has come out of of it
so thank you very much um there's a
fallacy of the you know over inquisitive
child who asks their science teacher um
you know who who
invented yeah who invented electricity
um you know to get in the sense that you
know obviously electricity was discover
but that sort of fous question gets the
point of the difference between what is
knowable and what is kind of usable
although there's a two um there's a kind
of an interesting relationship there I
think so I suppose my perhaps equally
simple question to you is uh was science
by which I mean the scientific method
invented or discovered and it's a bit of
a trick question because I think the
answer is probably that it was invented
I think probably all of you would agree
that's the case um so I think because of
that it sort of suggests to me that we
maybe can't choose what we find and
indeed the scientific method is
constructed to make sure that we can't
choose what we find but we can choose
what we look for and maybe to put it a
bit more perly but more succinctly we
can't choose what we find but we can
choose what we f
and there's there's you know a reason we
pour billions of dollars into cancer
research but not into know brues for
example um in ter so I think that that
maybe that um that decision- making is
our human agency over the scientific
process so I think maybe the the point I
put out there is that you know that the
reality is that there's a lot of reality
out there but the act of shining the
search light is our Act of
interpretation it's not technical
interpretation but it's the process of
discovery is a very powerful process
which we as humans and as scientists do
control no nobody would would quarrel
with you if if you say that what we end
up finding represents a subset of what
can be found in the objective outside
universe and that what we end up finding
is in no small part dictated by what
we've looked for and what we've looked
for is in no small part dictated by the
culture around us including the
political and the scientific culture but
still I would maintain that if a
scientist discovers something and it's
rigidly demonstrated that independent of
how he got or how she got to that point
the truth of what he or she discovered
will still be robust and survive the
test of
time well well I just wanted to respond
to your comment that that uh about the
development of the scientific method and
you said was it discovered or invented
and I think you said it was
invented um I think the scientific
method was was was was found
uh as a process of of
uh natural
selection intellectual natural
selection that um it's a method uh that
in Rebecca's language um a method of
inquiry that allows us to ask questions
and in a such a way that nature will
answer and those answers have allowed us
to develop antibiotics they've allowed
us to design cell phones and iPhones
they've uh improved the quality of life
they they pay off so we we found the
scientific method over time because it's
it's a method of of inquiry and of being
in the world that allows us to improve
our quality of life so I don't think
that you know
it's uh I think uh that one can apply
the same logic and argument to to its
development as we do to other things to
develop by natural selection yeah you
know David D in um he has a new book out
the beginning of infinity and um he
argues there
that any intelligence in the universe
would eventually come on our scientific
method that we don't have to worry you
know in all of this science fiction uh
that there is this kind of you
know Martian you know who who comes and
and and has a completely different way
of knowing um so he argues there that
you know this thing that we evolved um
amazing that it is it it is the way to
know what is and any intelligence in the
universe would have
um come on the very same
one I think you know I don't know if
that's true but but it's it's very well
argued if you sincerely believe that it
was kind of an cultural artifact a
scientific method then I would challenge
you to propose an alternative to the
scientific method that would equally
efficacious I think it's survived the
test of time um I mean just very brief
back to I just finished a project
looking at the impact of big data on the
social sciences and that's already talk
a little more slowly sorry yeah looking
at the impact of big data on the social
sciences and that's for me it's provoked
some of these questions in you because
the sort of the the general sense behind
it is that this is the we'll have n
equals all we'll have all the data in
the world we need not ask any more
questions but of course that's very much
a as well I think we do still need
questions and we'll still be the ones to
to ask them but I think as I think
that's absolutely right about the
scientific method I think it it's it's
the one it's maybe the least worst
option that we have so
far yes over here my name is Peter Walch
um I have had in my career several
experiences of working with Scientists
in a way which allowed me to see the
sausage making of Science and some of
this although I did not realize at the
time some of the science I was observing
being stuffed into casing was um
important it was a cuttingedge science
which is considered important today what
I concluded from that experience was
that the process of making science at
least from my observation was much
closer to a novel than it was to a
controlled experiment in other words
enormous amount of plot drama uh twists
suspense and
ambiguity uh contradictions twists and
turns um you talking not safe controlled
process and so my question is have we
made to some extent kind of a plaster
state of Science by kind of
ignoring the little messy Parts like um
Newton's Alchemy and and Galileo's uh
astrology and and so forth we making it
too simplified to really appreciate what
science is about and just a clarifying
question are you referring to the the
process of science so the way science is
done in a laboratory or are you
referring to I'm saying the process of
finding questions I'm saying that
without getting too running too far off
all the liable laws there were there was
a lot of personal stuff going on with
the process of Science and there was a
lot of people being upset anger
communicating in different ways refusing
to listen to each other refusing to
believe each other not coming together
um making accusations political
accusations mess of stuff I often say
the trouble with science is it's done by
human beings right biger I often say uh
maybe once a week the trouble with
science is it's done by human beings and
already twice tonight yes I've said it
twice tonight uh and uh the question to
my mind is not whether it's done by
human beings yes or to quote another
experience uh uh another saying the
reason why academic disputes such as
those in science are so nasty and bitter
is that the stakes are so low and and
um the question to me is not whether
science occasionally has personalities
and egom Manas in it the issue for me
and I think the issue for us tonight is
are the end results of the process as
messy and dirty and sausage making as it
is are the end results are they
something worthy of admiration and are
they robust and will they stand the test
of time independent of the egomaniacs
who created them I I don't mean to be
pejorative that process you're you're
perfectly privileged to
be prora because I know lots of
scientists who well your description and
the intention of my question is to
say um you know this watching this
process was fascinating to me and
watching how it worked is fascinating to
me and to me the messiness of it was and
the way the messiness was kind of
globbed together like lumps of clay
basically was an essential part of
science it wasn't an accidental part of
science it wasn't a negative part of
science um I think we we understand what
you're what's that I think we understand
what you're saying um the only reason
I'm cutting you off is because there we
don't have much time and we have some
more questions but uh I think you know
that's an it seems like that's an
argument for more histories of
science describing the process but I
think we I think we're clear so thank
you very much yeah uh so I have I'm an
undergraduate here studying just
identify yourself oh I'm Yuri Linsky I'm
an undergraduate here studying physics
the only one in the room maybe um and so
I have sort of a two-part question uh
the first one is that so in science
there's like a clear sense of progress
in the sense that you are sort of you
know climbing a ladder you have like you
do some you learn truths like that are
objectively true and as you accumulate
more of these facts you know some of
them might turn out to be not true under
different situations but ideally when
you publish a scientific paper you're
specific enough that you say under these
conditions what I'm saying is true and
that's just a fact and then maybe
you know like best example probably or
the easiest one is like Newton what he
said is still true under the conditions
that he assumed and we can still use his
laws we have additional ones because
we've probed further but we've made
objective progress um is there such a
thing in the humanities because you do
have a lot of like social conditions on
what the humanities are and something
that someone argued 10,000 years ago
there's no there's no reason that I see
that it's you know less valid today
whereas we can objectively say you know
science has made progress because we
have a larger like more gigabytes of
information uh and then the second
question I just we'll get them both out
quickly maybe uh the second question is
there's I've heard a lot and I've seen a
lot of uh Humanities people use you know
data methods and mathematical analysis
statistical methods um and sort of pull
from The Sciences to help uh to help
with what they're studying but are there
examples in I guess especially physics
but anywhere where actually the
humanities have facilitated in a direct
way what scientists have done and I'd
like to avoid you know politics or like
you know hum humanists have argued that
science is a good thing so it got
funding but something used directly by
scientists to Aid in the scientific
process
yeah yeah um I've argued um very
strongly various Publications that
philosophy makes progress um and in fact
um because one of the things that
philosophy is trying to do is to expand
our coherence um and that we it's it's a
a constant uh effort to um
unearth uh unexamined
presuppositions uh and um um and and and
to question them presuppositions that
are so constitu of our thinking that
they that they're completely um
invisible and that uh and it also makes
progress because science makes progress
and and philosophy is always trying to
use the uh the the uh results of Science
and to reconcile them with other of of
our intuition some of which have to go
um and so I mean right now for example
it's a very huge question whether or not
the results in neuroscience mean that we
have to give up very fundamental views
about Free Will personal agency
accountability um and this is uh you
know philosophy making progress
piggyback P piggybacking um on science
but it is you know there nobody's a
cartisian duelist anymore for example I
mean that was a very uh uh robust view
uh before we had made uh progress in
science but but but also I mean I me and
this is a huge argument um philosophical
um arguments has have helped us make
moral progress and in in uh uh
unearthing various inconsistencies in
our moral point of view um and so Plato
for example had a really good argument
as to why slavery was wrong for Greeks
right uh he had a but you know that
argument was was was then worked on and
uh universalize and you know slowly we
get uh a universal argument against uh
slavery that that it's it's not just
wrong to enslave Greeks but humans in
general so there there's that kind of um
of progress and it gets and and it
really is progress that proceeds by way
of arguments anyway that's a long
argument that I would make yeah to to
pick out that slavery point is so is
there like some kind of argument that
it's not possible to make another
argument that slavery is actually okay
yeah you know there's that sense of
Revelation that aha um when you when you
see that certain ethical commitments
that you've already made entail others
right and so um and so that's a kind of
growth expansion of of coherence so you
can give up you know the initial
intuitions or or you have to live with
the consequences right of and and and
apply them uh but in every place in
which slavery was abolished it was never
reinstituted except for um actually one
example of Napoleon in Haiti but in
general these advances are are kind of
discoveries they're kind of aha I'm
committed to this um I have to expand uh
my my commitments I'm I'm inconsistent
and that's the way it's been going on
ever since Socrates was plying his trade
uh in the Athenian agara he said a lot
of people uh by by asking them to
account consistently uh for their points
of view and they rewarded him with a
briming cup of Hemlock Rebecca I just
want to move on because we have only a
couple minutes and we have I think we're
only going to have time for one more
question I'm sorry um so Josh can you
identify yourself and ask your question
hi I'm Josh so uh I'm a student in the
graduate program for science writing
here at
MIT
so I've noticed Allan very cleverly
dealing with some of the Thor questions
of the nature of science by using what I
think is a constructive empiricist
argument about what science is so we can
avoid the question of whether science is
explaining or dealing with truth or
knowledge or what is actually there in
reality by instead saying that science
provides a useful set of explanations a
useful set of heris for
Learning and that's convincing to me and
I think that that's logically sound and
in the interest of given that this is
the last question of tying together
things with as need a bow as I can
manage is there a way to say that
science in the empiricist sense is about
heris that work and that are
demonstrably effective when compared to
other methods not about the nature of
reality but rather that science works
because it works and that Humanity also
has similar processes that are obviously
applied and although they cannot be as
rigorously defined they're still clearly
useful and informative ways to look at
the world and
humans in 30 seconds or less
well I I think that the discussions
about what reality
is are really not
scientific uh I think that that
ultimately science works because it's
able to make predictions about
experiments the results of experiments
that are outside of our
bodies and so I I agree with your char
characterization that it works because
it
works and any further characterizations
of it I
think uh drift into the
philosophical realm so you wouldn't say
that we know that there are Fons and
bosons neurons genes you're not
committed to those existing well when
you say we know them I think that we
that that that we that uh our theories
of them our equations about them allow
to make
uh predictions about the world outside
of us testability testability yeah so
but but it doesn't expand orology beyond
our
experiences well I think that's another
discipline to to two things before we
end one um I had wanted to bring up
girdle because I thought that that would
be a kind of uh a very nice way to
address some issues including math which
didn't come up at all um but the the
idea that there can be something that is
true but not provable um uh in
mathematics is sort of fascinating is a
fascinating underlying question for
those of you who don't know uh Rebecca's
written a book on girdle but Jim I
actually have one last question um for
you before we end and that's we've been
talking a lot about um sort of progress
in a scientific sense and as as a
novelist um when you look back over the
history of of of no no s and fiction
writing do you see what's happening as
progress well I think progress forgive
me is an ambiguous idea and uh but a
useful one also and I I would just say
the novel is a modern
form uh and it it presumes certain human
characteristics that have come into
flower in modernity especially
individual freedom and the important of
the individual and the importance of
experience I as a non-scientist I take
the basic meaning of the scientific
method to be experience Trump's
dogma and in the scientific method as
elaborated here experience is testable
and and able to be um not just argued
but demonstrated but if experience and I
think every novel subject in some way or
other
is experience Trump's Dogma or ideology
or ideas atas Shrugged the young man who
uh addressed us a few minutes ago asked
us to abstract from politics uh that's
the element that's been missing from
this discussion you can't abstract from
politics because the enlightenment in
addition to being an intellectual
Revolution was a political revolution
and at bottom it was about the coming uh
into power of individuals and that's the
ground of Science and it's the ground of
of uh contemporary literary
art uh because it requires as George
Orwell said the free play of the mind
which was impossible in the dictatorship
of dogmatism however
defined uh it's true it's political it's
also religious uh Orwell's quote was the
novel is a Protestant art
form requiring the free play of the mind
no Catholic can be a good
novelist or or if he is he's a bad
Catholic so which one which one are you
I'm a bad
Catholic um so I wan to I want to thank
um our panel uh and again remind
everyone that we will not only be having
a reception right outside um we will
also have books uh for sale um at the
beginning I I was so impressed by the
fact that Jim had just published a novel
in July that I changed the title of his
book to war in July it's actually
warberg in Rome I realized as soon as I
said it um uh but please join me in
giving a very very warm thanks to the
panel um and and and please buy books
also